-Hey, guys, it's time to take a look at the stories
making headlines today and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons." Here we go.
-♪ Pros and Cons and Pros and Cons and Pros ♪
-Tonight, we'll be taking a look at the pros and cons
of March Madness.
It's kicking off this week,
everyone's filling out their brackets,
so let's take a look at the pros and cons of March Madness.
Here we go. Pro...
Ah, yeah. Well... It happens.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, that's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Mmm! Could be!"
-Oh, that's -- Yeah, that's rough.
-Wow.
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-I thought hemp would be up there.
-No, no, no. -No?
Oh, that's... -What?!
[ Audience ohhs ]
Wow! You're taking some big --
[ Cymbal crash ] Taking some big swings tonight.
Wow. 90!
-And finally...
There you go, everybody. Those are the "Pros and Cons."